في ايران ايضا وملف الاحتجاجات الدم يسيل
في دم الوطن هكذا هتفت الانتفاضه الشعبيه
في ايران لتصر على استمرارياتها رغم كل
محاولات القمع والترهيب والتخويف من قبل
النظام الايراني هتافات النساء في لم تهدا
في حي بوناك في العاصمه طهران وصدى
اصواتهن اكد على الموت للديكتاتور الموت
لخامنئي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المظاهرات والاضرابات والتجمعات والهتفات
وحرق رموز النظام وغيرها من اشكال العصيان
المدني عمت مختلف المدن الرئيسيه في
البلاد وكما نشاهد على هذه الشاشه
مشاهدينا ادرار النار بتمثال لقاسم سليمان
قائد فيلق القدس السابق في مدينه كوبن
جنوب البلاد صحيفه وصله الامريكيه اشارت
الى ان الايرانيين استبدلوا احتجاجات
الشوارع المميته بحسب قولها باعمال تمرد
هادئه واهمها تخلي الاف النساء في ايران
عن الحجاب الالزامي هذه الخطوه اعتبرتها
الصحيفه الامريكيه شكلا من اشكال العصيان
المدنيه وقد لا تطيح بالنظام لكن سيكون من
الصعب احتوائها في المستقبل طبعا ولكنها
اشارت الى ان القيود التي فرضتها السلطات
لم يكن لها تاثير كبير موضحه ان التحول
العلمانيه في ايران اخذ في التوسع وفقه
وصفها والقمع هذا المسار الجديد فرض نظام
الايراني هذا الشهر غرامات على النساء
التي يخالفن قواعد اللباس في الاماكن
العامه
[موسيقى]